and i did get an email from
representative king he will show up a
little bit late
he has another meeting he's attending
okay and you are all set to go
as chairman of the house health human
services
and elderly affairs committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location
for the members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that one all members of
the committee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and that the public has access to listen
contemporaneously
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271
3600 or email
h c s at
leg dot state
dot nh dot
u s the phone number again is two seven
one
thirty six hundred in the event the
public is
unable to access the meeting that means
everyone
in the public the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer committee researcher will
be the staff
member assisting us please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states his or her
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting this is required
under the right
to know law so do i call the role or who
who calls the role you can today do you
have a clerk identified
i have a clerk and does the clerk have
the list of names handy
then i will do my clerk
emeritus duty before turning it over
to our new clerk
william marsh uh
thank you mr chairman i will point out
that you were supposed to say where you
were whether you were alone first but
i am currently in my home office in
brookfield and i am currently alone
charles mcmahon good morning all
i'm in my home office in wingham and i
am alone
bill nelson good morning mr chairman i
am in my home in brookfield new
hampshire and i am alone
dennis acton
betty gay
i'm i'm at home alone but my husband
could walk in the kitchen any old time
in salem leah cushman
good morning i am home in where
um i am alone in the room currently but
my kids or my husband
may come through beth folsom
hi i am the folsom i am in
wentworth and in my home
and my husband is in the house and could
walk through at any time
nikki kelsey hi i'm nikki kelsey i'm
home in bedford i'm currently
in my home office with my two dogs but
my husband could also walk through
as well bill king
bill king
jim kofalt good morning mr chairman
i am in my home office in wilton new
hampshire uh i am alone here
and there may be someone walking through
occasionally
lucy webber
here i i'm currently in concord not
walpole
and uh i am alone because the dog has
gone today
jim mckay
kendall snow
you're muted ken
[Music]
lower left corner okay got it now
got it now hello yeah
you were muted
you're muted again ken
and you need to unmute yourself
you can also press the oh there you go
there we go did i go okay
ken snow i'm in my home and my wife is
in the vicinity
where is your home manchester
jerry canarque yes hi jerry canarch here
i am home
alone in freedom in my study and my wife
just went to work so i'm alone alone
jeffrey soloway good morning i
am at home in lee new hampshire uh alone
but with the dog jerry cannon
hi jerry cannon i'm in somersworth new
hampshire
um i'm home alone in summersworth
actually
i have a couple of dogs that might try
and get in my lap
francis another oppam hello i'm i'm here
i'm in nashua everyone else in the house
is still sleeping so i'm alone
joe shapiro i am in my
home office in keene
by myself gary woods
uh good morning mr chairman i'm ian beau
and my study
at my home and i'm home alone
gary merchant good morning mr chairman
i'm in claremont new hampshire in my
home and i am alone
and this is mark pearson i'm in
my study in hampstead
and i'm alone and unfortunately i'm
douglas
and that completes the roll call
so christina what do you have for us
well i just wanted to introduce myself
to
folks on the committee i'll be your
researcher i know
representative pearson asked asked me to
give a little overview of what it is
that
that i do i believe house community
services will be giving a more formal
presentation about everything that they
do at a later date
but my main tasks i can actually
put something up for you to take a quick
look
so this is sort of an overview of what
committee research services does
so any research requests that you might
have about bills that do come in
you can certainly ask for but they must
be coordinated through the chair and
vice chair
so this could include any historical
comparative data
um research like any subject matter
legislative history
um several comparisons um side by sides
uh for senate bills um and then some
tracking
um you know i work hard to
make sure that there's some sort of
smooth workflow and i try to attend all
meetings and subcommittee work sessions
to make sure everything flows smoothly
um as you'll as you'll note you'll be
completing minority majority reports i
will also be proofing and editing those
to make sure that those are
um look good when they come out in the
calendar during your your sessions
um and you know i also serve as a guide
for
procedure if you have questions on that
as well
my email is i think you all have it now
i
emailed you multiple times but that's
in a nutshell what i'm doing it's also
important that i like to note that i
am that our office is uh non-partisan
so all of the information that comes is
for both parties
um and comes in and is an attempt to be
a brief overview of the materials
that can help you in your analysis of
the bills
and if there's any questions please let
me know
would you explain just in case any of
the new members
don't know what a side-by-side is
and how helpful it is absolutely um so a
side by side
might be for example a previous bill
there are certain versions an amendment
that might have come through
it would be quite literally a side by
side of
each of those amendments next to each
other and any of the changes
that might have happened through the
text i would highlight those changes
and the certain the outcome of those
particular changes
that can also be used when we go to
committee of conference in senate
for senate bills so you can take a look
at what the senate version looks like
and what the
house version looks like and that should
help you
kind of parse through the data to figure
out what the differences are
we will be getting some uh
redos or refilings of builds that we've
seen
before partially because they didn't
pass last time
and the sponsor wants to try it again
sometimes
because the bills got to the senate and
they didn't get attached to anything so
they died on the table and we're back
again
in some cases the bills will be the same
as we saw last time or the time before
but i know with a couple of my bills i
took the occasion
to make some slight changes would it be
possible for us to request side by sides
with one side being last time and the
other side being this time
you could certainly do that i do like to
note that i am staffing five committees
at the moment um so um certainly happy
to help as much as possible i do also
have all the bill files
from last session so if you're looking
at bills that have already gone through
a public hearing that died on the table
because of our session
last um last spring i can also take all
of that testimony and
you could take a look at the bill file
as it exists um
from last time so we want to be kind to
you and do it
only when we really think it's necessary
and not just because we like to generate
work
i appreciate that okay
um what now of the
secretary that used to be in the
committee office
and the various things she did i know
when i was clerk there are numbers of
things
where she and i would have to meet and
i recalled that the various chairs
did similar since we're not there and
i'm not
sure and i read that the offices
committee offices are not
open uh what of
uh some of the things we used to do with
her now go to you or what
so uh your committee assistant this year
is going to be
uh take a look it's going to be lindsey
forcier
uh and so you know she would be working
on electronic amendments and they're
we're working on getting an electronic
bill file together
um and then so any um
[Music]
any i.t issues that you might be having
any
um well typically copying
you know that sort of thing um providing
up those
paper copies that again is
being worked out as of right now the
fourth floor is completely closed
um so uh there will be there won't be
any contact if there's something that
you need
from from us or from the clerical staff
then you can call
271 3600
and make your request there um for those
of you who may actually go in purpose
in person excuse me if there's something
that you need um
we request that you give us some notice
and you call up to the the fourth floor
at 3600
let them know that you need something
and then we'll filter it down that way
will we go up to get it or will it be
there on
the table in the double wide committee
room
it would be downstairs on the table so
the goal is to limit
exposure um and anything that's
requested would be
in the committee room available to you
it sounds to me
that those of us who may not have an
immediate printer
availability should look into that i
have one at my office office
but i don't have a working one at my
home office but i just put that on my
to-do
list because if we ask for something you
might send us a link and we'd have to
print it out
representative kanark yeah just a real
quick question that two two seven one
thirty six hundred because i know
a lot of phones are not being answered
as people are not working there is that
one that people actually answer during
the day
yes there's someone there in the office
monitoring every day
and then also what is could you tell us
your telephone number that where we can
actually reach you are you
on site and we can reach you there i'm
not on site but the
um the number is forwarded to my home so
my
my line is 271 3385.
thank you you're welcome and in terms of
lindsay
uh for ca she was our assistant last
time and
we will find out her phone number and
specifically what she's going to do
when that's been worked out correct
we're in the process of right there
right now
representation there's no phone number
at this point
correct not yet hands please
representative weber
thank you mr chair um i i am assuming
that we also
have the um admonition that we have had
in the past
that uh those who need ms dyer
except for things like i can't get onto
the pho
i can't get onto the phone call uh need
to go through you when it's
when it's substantive work so that she
so that the committee needs are
prioritized and so that she isn't having
to answer phone calls from
26 times 20 22 times five people
is that correct yeah most things should
go through me
as last time they went through you yeah
any other questions of yes
representative folsom
thank you um can you please repeat
lindsay's last name
for me yes uh forcier f-o-r-c-i-e-r
thank you you're welcome
her grandfather would have pronounced it
foisie
most likely
anyone else questions of christina
then i would like to start at least
representative um marsh and i have to
leave at about 9
50 for a chair and vice chair meeting
but at least in the half an hour we have
left i think we can
begin introduction and
tell us when i call on you tell us your
name the town or towns you represent
uh why you wanted to be on this
committee
what your work your other job your day
job is or was
a few interesting little facts about
yourself don't go more than about three
minutes but
we can learn a lot in three minutes the
only new person
from the democrat side to our committee
is gary merchant and
we're so glad you're with us you spent a
lot of time with us anyway
as the only pharmacist in the house and
some of us put in a strong request for
you
should there have been a vacancy and
there was so gary tell us
what i haven't told them about you well
thank you mr chair
for that introduction um my name is gary
merchant i'm a
second term representative from
claremont i represent
ward 2 in the city i'm now retired
prior to my retirement i worked as a
pharmacist
in several different arenas the last one
was at mary hitchcock memorial hospital
known as dartmouth hitchcock medical
center
i was responsible for the club which was
a group of 17 hospitals working with the
medical center in realm of trying to
coordinate pharmacy activities
the reason why i want to be on the
committee is that i think it fits very
well with my
expertise and after chairman pearson
made the comment i was
before you committed quite many several
times last year
and i learned to respect a lot of the
intellect
the work that you folks are working on
and also the bills that were before you
my
expertise in my background in pharmacy
would lend itself
to the committee and become an asset to
it i've lived in klamath all my life
i've been a resident here for many years
obviously
i reside here now with my wife i have
three daughters
um five grandchildren so i've been
blessed
um but that's kind of who i am and i
look forward to working with everyone on
this group
in this committee thank you so much
let's uh call upon the rookie
uh republicans start with uh bill king
or not nikki kelsey
good morning thank you mr chairman good
morning everybody my name is nikki
kelsey
i live in bedford i am a study at home
mom
i have a 14 year old daughter um
some interesting facts about me i was a
flight attendant for many years
and then i retired doing that and i
opened a
registered daycare center which i owned
and operated
and i just want to be on health and
human services because it's where my
heart is it's where my passion is
and i'm really looking forward to
working with each and every one of you
and most importantly learning from all
of you
with your expertise in the field so
thank you so much
representative kelsey are you a lifelong
bedford
native or did you come here from
somewhere else no
so i've lived all over the country um
i'm originally from kansas city
i've lived all the way from california
to new york down to florida and then
back up here
so i've been all over the wonderful
united states
thank you representative acton has
joined the meeting i'll call on you for
a bio later but
you need to let us know where you are
and if you're alone
all right thank you i'm having a little
bit of hardware difficulty i am in my
kitchen i am all alone
uh how how's my audio sound
not too good a little weak okay
and home is what town uh fremont
uh i'm down in fremont okay thank you
very much we'll get back to you uh beth
folsom your intro
thank you uh mr chair that um
my name is beth folsom i live in
wentworth and i represent
wentforce dorchester and kanan
i have kind of a unique reason why i
wanted to be on health and human
services
and elderly affairs partly because my
degree is in social work
with an emphasis on gerontology and
i um also used to live in colorado
and i was an aide for nine years to a
state senator
who chaired health and human services
um so um i did it during the whole
period
when marijuana came on board so
marijuana bills and i are very familiar
um and uh so this is just an area that
is always interested me
and i felt like i wouldn't have as much
time needed to play catch-up
thank you so much and you are are you
native to colorado
uh no i'm native to connecticut
then i went to college and met my
husband in minnesota
and we he is a colorado native so that's
how we ended up there
but we also spent three years living in
alaska
um well
did somebody just sign in who hasn't
been on earlier mr chair i think someone
signed out
signed out okay uh let's see where am i
beth folsom leah cushman
thank you mr chairman um my name is leah
cushman i live in ware and i represent
hillsborough county district 2
which is wear and deering this is my
first term
i'm a registered nurse i've been in
nursing for six
six years i wanted to be on this
committee because it's most relevant to
my profession and body of knowledge
health is a passion of mine i'm married
my husband is a stay-at-home dad and
homeschooler to our three boys
we have a dog a cat two goats and ten
chickens out here and
i'm a native to massachusetts but i
moved to new hampshire in 2017
and i spent probably half my childhood
in new hampshire
at a campground in raymond where in new
hampshire where in massachusetts
um i grew up in reading okay it's like
15 minutes north of boston
right all right thank you uh betty gay
yes um i'm happily moved
from election law to health and human
services
uh both are my passion and i've been
fascinated by medicine ever since i was
nine and started reading the medicine
column
in time magazine so i'm very happy
that you know that i got assigned here
um
it is you know great interest to me
i live in salem i was born in galveston
grew up in texas attended lamar which is
a university now
with a degree in chemistry and that's
the only degree i have
thank you oh oh did you know at 10
o'clock
from 10 to 11 there is a zoom
presentation uh against
drug abuse and the third presenters
are the students from the high school i
can't remember always say they're from
dover
and they're not um it's the organization
that you hear psas from
from teenagers uh it's a
a joint effort sponsored by the police
in town
but but they've been doing psas on the
radio for years
public service announcements where do
where would one find the link to get on
to that meeting
well i'll what i can do is find it and
tell me who to forward it to and who
would have the whole list to help
everybody well for the moment
it would be probably a past
email that came to all of us from
christina
that would possibly be the most accurate
or you could hit that one stop shopping
h h
s e a at
yeah thank you
sounds like a railroad you know okay
thank you dennis acton please a little
bio
of yourself okay uh sorry about the
connection issues i'm trying to get an
old laptop fired up for
for um remote use but um anyway back
onto my
my iphone which always works with zoom
um yeah so
uh once again my name is dennis acton
i'm um actually this is my second term
and my second time on the health and
human services and um
hallelujah affairs committee um i loved
it last time it was something that was i
think
really special to all of us despite the
trouble we ran into and i'm very much
glad to be back
uh real briefly my background is i'm a
nine-year military veteran
um i have a uh
i have a uh
i have i have a communications degree a
bachelor's of science from southern
connecticut state university
and i wound up moving up to new
hampshire in 1994 where i was a
worked in high tech and i was i was in a
variety of high-tech startups
a lot of them medical related so that's
why i started gaining
medical knowledge and then i was an i.t
director for
a busy medical firm for many years uh
which gave me the
the knowledge of insurance billing and
the how the systems work in the
background working with new hampshire
and medicaid
and federal medicare and so forth so i
have a lot of
background in that which gives you a
good basis to move forward but in
general
my reason for being here
is to represent
the the um working parents that's
something that
that um got me elected here in my town i
won by almost two-thirds
boat and got out spent 30 to one um but
i i focus on
representing working parents and also um
the the low-level medical providers
healthcare people my wife is a
home care physical therapist she's been
in the thick of
covet from from the get-go and uh so i
have a unique perspective
of in an ear to the ground on what's
going on out there
at the patient level at the family level
and that gives me a unique perspective
coming into health and human services
too thank you representative acton we're
going to be moving on
uh representative uh bill nelson
thank you mr chairman my name is bill
nelson and i'm a retired school teacher
and school administrator
and in my fifth term i represent
brookfield wakefield ossipee in
effingham
um i'm very pleased to see the broad
spectrum of members of this committee
i grew up in new jersey from there i
moved to vermont and i've been in new
hampshire for about 25 years
my interest has been working with the
elderly and homebound through a
church-related ministry and my wife
who's very very big into working with
people that are in nursing homes etc
that's it
representative nelson when you were
school teacher what population did you
teach
i've taught everything but the primary
thing was special ed as a teacher an
administrator
was both a principal and a special ed
director
special ed would relate to part of what
we do
representative mcmahon
yes good morning mr chairman thank you
for the opportunity to
introduce myself my name is charlie
mcmahon i'm out of the
town of windham and i'm in starting my
10th term on the committee which is a
distinct honor
and the environment of learning how you
can truly help the greatest amount
of new hampshire citizens in one
location uh what i've learned from my
colleagues
that are on the board even now is how to
be an aggressive advocate with manners
and that's something uh that i've
learned that we need to do here to get
things done while we're young
which means do it today so i'm hoping to
work
closely together with everyone and uh
i'm anxious for the year to get started
thank you mr chairman and you are our
coordinator
of appropriate expediting with the great
phrase
let's do it while we're young uh what is
the other phrase we know you for
what are old people really uh you're
aggressively mature
thank you
of course that's debatable so but that's
that's for another another session
representative marsh
i've lost my co-chair thank you very
much mr chairman there he is he's
okay i i had to unbeat myself here
and thank you everybody it's a pleasure
to be here today
uh this is my third term in the house uh
representing the southern half of
carroll county inflatorial district
uh and uh it is my third term on health
and human services which i very much
enjoyed and wanted to come
back again as far as history i grew up
in western pennsylvania
moved to new hampshire as a dartmouth
student in 1975 and ended up staying
i practiced ophthalmology as a
solo practitioner and a sole proprietor
for approximately 30 years before i
retired i've also served as trustee of
huggins hospital since 2004 including
two terms as the corporate treasurer
i've served as the moderator of the town
of brookfield since 2010
i've served as the health officer of the
town of brookfield since 2002
and this is our first year that we're no
longer homeschoolingly
yet so we have that in common we uh my
last of my five children
is now off to connecticut college and uh
we no longer have that responsibility
we've similarly cut back on the number
of animals we now have four chickens
left
and no longer have sheep and alpacas so
we have that in common as well so it's a
pleasure working with you all and i'm
sure we'll have a nice
nice year working together thank you so
much
representative woods good morning mr
chair
um i'm gary woods i'm originally from
california
um grew up there actually my high school
is american graffiti
movie uh george lucas was a high school
classmate uh i went to berkeley
went to berkeley in physics and then
hopkins in biophysics
got lost in the east coast went to
rochester for medical school
became stayed on the faculty as a
orthopedic hand surgeon
for five years and then came here in 82
retired a few years ago along the way i
was involved with the legislature with a
variety of commissions perhaps
10 or 12 commissions over the years a
variety of policy positions both state
and nationally and
ama and the han society and the uh and
the state medical society
so both my uh technical background
as well as my policy with a variety of
positions has served me well
and obviously i have a committed
interest
to the topic in health and human
services
it's important to know that he was a
hand surgeon
i found that out when he took my hand i
realized immediately he wasn't being
fresh he was
checking out my dupa train right
dupatron french
okay so in case he comes and takes your
hand
don't be surprised he is being very
professional
representative shapiro
thank you mr chair um i
am a transplant from new york i have
lived in
keene for over 30 years
and um i represent
one of the um at large seats for the
city of keene
by profession i've had a career as a
clinical social work
er from which i retired about a year ago
i worked with in numerous venues
schools community mental health private
practice over the years so i have a
strong interest in mental health
um i have two
adult daughters and
what else um dogs
dogs i have a very strong interest
in um competitive croquet
oh that's it yeah okay
you're on sometimes that will be a
competing um
a competing interest and um scheduling
issue
i was threatened with expulsion from
oxford
because i played croquet american style
and not british style and they
a certain person of power did not like
that well but he had mercy on me so i
stayed so maybe we could have a
committee tournament
i'll trick you on yeah all right
representative nadarapam all right i'm
on uh pie fran nutter upham i represent
ward six in nashua
uh i moved to new hampshire when i was
14 with my parents to merrimack where i
graduated from merrimack high
i lived in new york new jersey
switzerland ireland maryland i don't
remember
i was actually born in illinois but they
moved quickly
as an adult i've lived in um
england holland and several summers in
poland
you know teaching in english language
programs with my four children
i'm a art psychotherapist i went to
i was a stay-at-home mom you know pretty
much
in my early 40s i went to graduate
school so i've been an art
psychotherapist for 22 years
last year i was retired this year i took
a job
with the courier museum of art as an art
therapist
working with veterans and their families
um an initiative that's just getting
started and it's going to be great wow
um i've got i said the four
kids four chickens uh one cat
two grandsons one of whom has been
diagnosed with muscular dystrophy
a little fella who's 10. so you know
last year we heard uh rare disease
uh registries and you know so now all
that stuff is kind of
hitting home he's doing great for now
we're hoping for gene therapy
so you know anyway i'm excited for
everyone's expertise on this committee
and
the best committee
representative cannon
hi um uh jerry cannon i currently um
and representative for stratford 18
which is uh
for the five awards in somersworth and
ro the small town of rollinsford
i've i grew up in sudbury massachusetts
and moved up to new hampshire 43 years
ago
so i've spent more time here than i did
in massachusetts
i have two daughters one happens to be a
formulation scientist at
pfizer and was involved with bringing
that vaccine to market
she's my resource from a
pfizer perspective um
i my background i was in the computer
industry
for 30 31 years
and then i was in the construction field
where i was a
general contractor in merrimack
then i was a truck driver for five years
and drove 550 000 miles
in the us cross country
i'm now a part-time carpenter
but i'm also a i'm also sitting on my
on the somersworth school board this is
my second term
i'm involved with the community action
partners and i've spoken at nami
conferences
on issues associated with the lgbt
community especially the transgender
population
i am one of about 10 transgender
state legislators across the country
and a leader here in new hampshire
and that's it in a nutshell thank you
thank you very much
uh jeff soloway uh good morning
everybody
um jeff salloway representative from
stratford five
that's the town of lee downtown
metropolitan league in fact
right i am professor emeritus
from university of new hampshire where i
chaired the department of health
management and policy
and taught epidemiology my particular
research
interests were in neurological diseases
particularly alzheimer's disease
and kidney diseases and i am now doing
participant observation research
in both of those topic areas there's a
little joke in there if you think about
it
and i'm i have found on this committee
not only a fabulous
college i use the word advisedly of
uh expertise but um a group
of very devoted colleagues and friends
uh it's a joy to be on this committee
and i thank you all for your
efforts by way of full disclosure when
he threatened
recently not to run again i threatened
him back
and look what happened so this this is a
standing order
jeff we we've got you as long as we want
you
which will be a long time jerry kanerk
yeah hi yeah okay i'm immunity i'm jerry
canerk and i'm state rep for
carroll county district 3. i live in
freedom i cover madison tamara's albany
and freedom
i grew up actually in michigan but then
way back
uh many years ago went out to boston for
medical school at harvard and also for
orthopedic residency and then
i became a uh orthopedic spine surgeon
and did that for many years till
arthritis and my thumbs knocked me out
of surgery
and so then i moved up to new hampshire
in 2007
where i ran a non-operative spinal
practice i started it and ran it and
took care of people with spine problems
kind of like their primary care doc for
back problems
um i retired in 15 ran for state rep and
i'm now my third
term beginning my third term
other jobs that i do i'm actually also
the chair of the
new hampshire therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board currently
serving as the vice chair
of the state health assessment state
health improvement plan advisory council
which
is the meeting i'm supposed to be at
right now and along with bill
um and uh but the but uh yeah you know
what
you can't clone yourselves so anyway um
so i do have those couple of other
uh hats that um are there and if those
of you are new
the longer you are here the more you're
going to get those little extra hats to
wear which is actually quite good and
quite interesting
um it's a great committee already been
alluded to we really work together very
well we don't really care about
partisanship we work together and try to
figure out what's going to be the best
solution
and for outside activities my major
outside loves are
outside sports um like if i didn't have
these meetings today
i would probably be skiing and swimming
and biking and kayaking and gardening so
that's that's me in a nutshell retired
orthopedic spine surgeon and
now working as a legislator works for me
and and for us thank you ken snow
gotta unmute unmute can unmute can
can you have to unmute
we're going to have to give him a
sticker to put right next to that spot
on his screen
stickers are good
i'm going to use it at this point and it
won't do it
you're good now we can hear you oh good
i don't know why it says i can't but
anyway i'm ken snow
i live in manchester uh represent ward
12 here in manchester which is on the
west side
i'm in my fourth term all of which i've
served on the health human services and
elderly affairs committee
and thoroughly enjoy my participation in
that
career-wise i'm a social worker as jo
sharing joe shapiro's background
worked for over 50 years in the
community mental health field 48 of
those here in new hampshire
i was a social worker and an executive
at the mental health center greater
manchester i retired in
2014 when i was a vice president of
community relations and development
uh i have a close working relationship
with the other community mental health
centers and the association that
represents them
i'm also involved with a number of other
mental health providers including the uh
the
state hospital and other mental health
providers and that's a
keen interest of mine
i think otherwise i have i'm married
i've married a new hampshire girl even
though i grew up in worcester
massachusetts
and you know you can't take worcester
out of the boy
grew up but anyway i think i've overcome
a lot of those handicaps over the years
and i'm considering granite state or
even though the rest of new hampshire
will
never consider me anything but a
carpetbagger
but um i'm very interested in a number
of topics
uh related to mental health and work
very closely with that but i also just
in healthcare in general it's
decided area of interest we do have a
subdivision of health and human services
that looks at mental health
substance abuse and suicide and i hope
i hope to be involved in that
subdivision of the
committee this year i should also say
that a fellow committee member jim mckay
and i
started a group called the bipartisan
mental health caucus
the purpose was to move ahead the
10-year mental health plan that was
put forward in 2008 in the hope that we
could
educate legislators and other community
leaders to make sure that
plan moves ahead the last 10-year plan
we had never really did move ahead
so we don't want to keep some attention
on that plan and get people's
motivation to move it along but we've
been running some
in-service programs prior to covid
that were well attended by members of
the legislature from both parties
and we hope to resume that once we're
past all this isolation that we're
involved in right now and
other than that i'm really looking
forward to my fourth term in the
committee
thank you so much ken lucy weber
chair emerita
thank you mr chairman i'm lucy weber
i live in walpole
and i represent walpole westmoreland
chesterfield and hinsdale so the lower
left-hand corner of the state
um i started out i was
uh grew up in new york city which i
hated
because it was urban we had a summer
camp in northern new jersey that was
very rudimentary
and which i loved a lot more so
when i had control over where i lived i
i
my residence was new jersey rather than
new york and from there i came to
vermont and from there
i crossed the river i was just just on
the other side of the river in
brattleboro and then
before that in the upper valley so i've
lived my adult life
up and down both sides of the
connecticut river basically
and it's very interesting to see how
much the connecticut river valley
is not a part of either new hampshire or
vermont
and is equally neglected by both of the
states
there belonged to i
started out as a teacher i went to law
school
my practice wound up being in elder law
so the problems of an aging population
are something that i
really am fascinated by so i am
uh the committee's token attorney but
i'm good at drafting stuff and i'm glad
to help
everybody with wordsmithing whether i
agree with the sentiment or not
and i have
served on judiciary edna children and
family law legislative administration
but this really feels like my home i've
spent two and a half
terms here eight terms in the house
entirely
uh but this really does feel like my
home and
um i think
that's it i will say that um i i
was very sad when our vice chair from
last time polly campion decided not to
run again
because she not only was very able
she brought the perspective of a nurse
so i'm glad we have another nurse
who is going to continue that point of
view
and uh i guess in terms of
family i have
no children but i have an enormous
extended family both because my sister
used up my allocation of children
and so i've got lots of nieces and
nephews and because my late husband came
with a very large family before i
met him i will also add that i
looked after my husband in his last
illness which was prostate cancer and he
was quite ill for four years
and so i bring the perspective of a
caregiver of a sick relative
and i know that the other thing that all
of us bring
are our own life experiences with our
own
family members and the care that we need
to
give both to them and to our communities
and uh it's why this is such a rich
a committee that is so rich in
experience of
all kinds and and they're all uh
both listened to and valued and it's why
i like serving here
so thank you all thank you so much bill
king
a brief bio of yourself
after you've unmuted
representative king please unmute
sorry about that okay um good morning
uh and thank you mr chairman for um
allowing me to introduce myself and uh
give you a little background
i'm uh bill king and i'm from uh milford
uh which is hillsborough district 23
for those um keeping track of that
um i am a transplant from new york but
i'm from the
upstate adirondack area of new york
which is very very similar to the new
england area
so when i moved to new hampshire
in 93 it was a very easy transition
so um i spent
after high school i spent four years in
the navy and which
helped pay for my college education i
became an engineer
and i've worked in manufacturing for
over 30 years
and um i'm not
very well uh suited for corporate
so um when the chance came i
semi-retired
and now i'm in legislation so
um uh i've
uh i've got four kids which you can see
in the picture by the way
for whatever reason uh i don't know if
it's a firewall here
where i am um but i can't actually turn
my camera on
but um the picture is uh
of my four kids and i've got three boys
and a daughter
um all basically of um
legal age and um
that's left me to dabble in
uh in different things we did lose my
wife
uh four years ago to sarcoma
and um this picture actually was taken
right after
she had passed and uh we did
a therapy vacation in california
any rate um uh in the recent years
um uh substance misuse
has been something that i've been um
involved in um uh through new hampshire
alliance uh
i'm also uh connected with a good
samaritan network
which has done a lot with
substance misuse and my office in
milford
is right next to addiction recovery
coalition of new hampshire
and so i'm closely tied to
addiction recovery and um
within my church i've got several people
that suffer from mental illness so
i'm definitely looking forward to
working with this committee
in those areas um
i guess that's about it um i am this was
my first year
so i'm a freshman and um drinking from
the fire hydrant right now
thank you and i'm mark pearson and
i am your chairman i grew up in
leominster massachusetts
which could be called but we refuse to
metropolitan
worcester and
i went to williams college for my
undergraduate degree in history
and then oxford came calling with a bag
of money and who was i to turn them down
so i did the master's degree in oxford
and later my doctorate at boston
university
representative soloway yeah um i was
ordained in the episcopal church in
1974.
i pastor a church part-time in kingston
my wife is a family practice physician
and together we started a faith-based
non-profit
center of wellness which brings together
family practice medicine we have three
providers
counseling massage therapy and prayer
and sacramental ministry of healing
i'm part-time ceo primarily in the area
of long-range
visioning and in fundraising
i came into this committee with
representative marsh and saloway and
canaric in that great class of 2016
and loved it and loved it the last two
years and i'm loving it now
mary ellen mckay who was in our
committee and i
nicknamed us the cool kids because most
of us
in high school weren't we were banned
geeks
or we were lab rats and now in our
dotage
we are truly the cool kids i have three
adult children
one is a corrections official in a
maximum security prison
the other uh was a public school teacher
and is now homeschooling
and the third one the eldest is a
stephen
a fire lieutenant in manchester studying
for the captain's test
and he serves in the house of
representatives in the eda
um committee um i have
three grandchildren each one of which is
my favorite
i lost my basset hound two years ago and
i'm trying to figure out how it can work
with everything i do to get another one
and so far
it's not happening so i'm glad to be
here this is truly
the best committee i owe an immense
amount of debt to representative
kotovsky to use his polish pronunciation
and especially to representative weber
for
modeling in two different styles what
committee
chairs should be like and indeed can be
like
so thank you and i look forward to
working alongside both
representative marsh as my vice chair
and representative weber
as the ranking member of
what our british friends call the party
opposite so that's us
and a couple of us several of us have to
scoot and
we will be convening at 10 o'clock on
tuesday the link for this meeting comes
from dhhs
and it's the meet and greet of all those
cool people that we have been seeing a
lot of on television
and it was fun my wife got sick of me
saying oh i know that person when so and
so was on tv because i always come to
our committee
because we're the health and human
services committee and they're
the department so with that i'll say
goodbye to everybody
and jerry do you have a is that hand to
say goodbye or what
just a real quickie on my screen on the
tile view that
i am sitting immediately next to you so
i can
give you the elbow for those who are new
mark sat next to me and we always
elbowed each other mostly he elbowed me
thank you well all right then i want to
tell one concern of the former chair
who has a very good um
ability with the hairy eyeball because i
used to teach second
grade too which is often why i took my
glasses off but i do want to say one
story about representative penarch and i
there was an issue and i forget what it
was but you wound up
arguing to the right it was it was to
prohibit conversion therapy and we've
we argued opposite sides we opposite
argued
we argued opposite to our party ideology
because somebody needed to bring up the
other side and it just seemed to be fair
so
this kind of thing i'm not sure how many
committees this could happen
and but it will happen in hours and
kotowski couldn't take
our elbowing any longer which is why he
made me clerk one years to separate us
yeah actually just a real quick thing
and the conversion therapy the other
story i liked and this is for this whole
committee to understand
mark and i argued because i was with my
side on that one and
mark was with his side we argued at the
well we saw each other at lunch and gave
each other a hug
that's the point we can disagree and we
can still love each other and that's
what we've got to do
more stories for later folks but
question okay ken because it's your
question
for next tuesday the 19th i do have that
10a meeting you just spoke about
but i also had a notice that we had a 9
a.m
zoom meeting on tuesday is that not
correct
who has one health human services and
elderly affairs
that this committee had a meeting
followed by the get acquainted meeting
with the health and human services
people
now that's that's this meeting okay so
okay no i mean the 10 a.m is the one
where the people from
department of health and human services
introduce themselves is that not correct
yes but this committee committee has no
nine o'clock meeting
okay just the test i'm giving you an
hour off
again i have one more scheduling
question
are are we usually going to meet it on
fridays
we have no idea who is we of uh this
committee
yes sir or this we don't know yet
it depends on how the room allocation
is i have things i have to do and i
can't make appointments
until i know but we are told we should
be
told very soon and i'm pushing them on
that and in the meeting i'm about to go
to
i'll push them again and if in that
meeting i find out i will get right back
to you because you have
meetings to set up too i do and and
friday's a great day
and so is monday just saying well okay
gotta go now one more question
oh joe because it's you um
we're all special huh you are i love you
all equally
so um i'm trying to schedule another
meeting and i'm wondering if we have any
indication of how long
the january 19th meeting will go
not afternoon they're going to troop
everybody before us because they don't
have to go outdoors they can do it on
zoom so we're going to meet
everybody including custodial on
next tuesday so but i told them at noon
they would be turned into pumpkins
so not past noon thank you
goodbye everybody bye hey i just said
the email
i just sent the email about the sam
meeting about the
substance abuse seminar
bye everybody with nice to meet you nice
to see you